You walk off stage and get on that fucking thing.
You feel like a king.
You got a driver.
What do you give a fuck?
You don't give a fuck about anything.
I can be on the road forever and that and just make an x on that little stove
top.
No,
you were in there drinking.
You're doing what you want.
You watching Goodfellas are fucking anchorman.
That is pretty beautiful.
It's so well it's an experience to your riding in that thing.
That's a retro experience as not just a truck.
Yeah.
That thing I,
you know my wife's nixed it.
What do you,
what are you going to put away?
I got the fucking driver.
We'll keep it.
I don't need it.
She was right.
My wife's always going.
Not always,
but mostly women don't like when you collect shit like where are you going to
put that?
They don't like that.
You get too many things.
That's half the reason why I got this place.
Collect shit here.
Oh yeah.
Nobody could say nothing.
This spot when one says nothing.
No,
but then it becomes,
you spend more time down here then you do up here though.
I've got it.
I got it nailed.
I figured it out.
Get up.
Berlin.
He being such a jerk.
That's why they don't have a point.
I don't.
I actually,
I can actually refute your opinion,
your point or whatever.
It's so universal too.
All women have that response like,
the fuck is wrong with you,
man.
They are.
We had a highway.
Yeah,
that's it.
Well,
imagine being them watching you imagine being a woman.
Have taken care of your children.
You know,
you give birth,
you get this little tiny infant and then financially you're relying on this
fucking maniac south.
They're flying helicopters and fixing cars.
I know.
Playing drums all day.
He's like,
what long as the money keeps coming in,
they can't say anything,
but they're like,
what the fuck are you doing?
The end of the day,
you married an eight year old,
you would have married a comedian.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
You're lucky.
We're not drug addicts.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'm,
I'm a,
I got,
I got to work on myself,
man.
I got to fucking,
you know,
I just,
yeah,
I am a difficult person to live with.
Evidently.
I didn't realize it,
but like,
I'm now looking at it honestly stepping back and look,
I go,
yeah,
I can see that.
I can fucking see that.
I've thought about it.
I'm definitely difficult.
Well,
if you don't think about it,
they'll remind you.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I would just
imagine relying on me,
I mean,
I'm reliable.
Like
I'm not,
I want to be like,
look,
responsible.
You could have married the me that worked in a fucking warehouse and I would
have been the same thing,
you know?
And we would be in a fucking studio apartment.
Here's the deal,
though.
They weren't married yet.
They would have found someone better.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you were just fucking off.
Never got your shit together.
You know,
when he's about limit too is their ability to move on.
Yeah.
Ooh.
Well,
I've always said like,
if I ever fucking died,
how quickly all my clothes would be at down at the goodwill,
you know,
and she'd just be like,
sell the house.
That's just burns.
Sage.
That was interesting.
All right,
well next step to the plate.
All my discussions with biologists and people who study like what?
What's Gads ads?
Uh,
what is his discipline?
Behavioral Psychology,
but he studies,
you know,
motivation,
Gad sad.
Is that his last name of his fullness?
That's his first name.
Gad.
S.
A.
D is His last name.
Does it rhyme because it also Ryan,
he's Canadian evolutionary behavioral scientist.
Brilliant guy.
He was so non,
does his name still rhyme?
It's a good question.
Is there anywhere he can go?
No.
Let me just,
my name is Gad said No.
He calls himself the Godfather.
He's,
oh,
so he just steered into it.
He's a great guy.
Couldn't imagine he's 13 but brilliant.
At least talking about.
Why would you name me mom?
Gad Sad.
I don't think sad means the same thing over there.
You know,
differently,
but end of the day it rhymes.
There's no country you can be on.
You can be on that fucking little island where they shot that guy with the
arrows and they get,
they going to make fun of you.
Still probably kick you off the island can.
You can't name your see like some of these celebrities,
some of the fucking names they named their kids.
It's just like,
don't you remember school?
You don't remember how fucking mean kids were.
Why are you giving that point?
Painting a fucking by.
Get it your creative.
Yeah,
have a meditation room.
Fucking don't do that with the name.
Oh,
give him a nice bill name.
William.
This is folding chair Johnson.
People need to express themselves and they do it through the naming of their
children,
children.
My other favorite thing and what they do is when they fucking,
they put their political agenda on them like the kid doesn't even have a fucking
chance.
Like this whole thing,
like a gender roles.
They bs.
By the way,
that my little experience being a dad,
going to kid birthday parties,
they,
those kids are not old enough for that behavior to be learned through.
The kids come,
the boys show up.
It is fucking brave heart.
They come all over the fucking hill.
Yeah.
The girls are social.
They're sitting there that kind of the taking things in enough kids.
Boys come in a fucking dude.
Ah,
we were at one on Saturday and there was this,
this kid who's hilarious.
He looked like a little Bobby Hurley is a point guard.
Right.
And um,
he was playing this game,
he had like this ball and he was using his,
his is like forums is a bat and he was hitting it,
then he would catch it.
Then he would throw it between his legs and he's doing all his brothers gets kid
hand.
Eye Coordination was great for his age.
So over in the corner where I was sitting with my daughter was these like little
like sort of like cushions that someone had put together like three piece thing
and made it into like a little chair for.
So an old person like me could sit down.
So I stood up because I was worried the ball was going to hit.
So I was kinda guarding that.
So he went over and got the ball at one point and just seeing the chair there,
you know,
all built like that.
He just saw it and just kicked it,
destroyed it and then continued on.
I was thinking like,
why did he do that?
Because he's a boy.
He's a boy.
Yeah.
We like ruined shit.
Well you got a lot of energy.
Little kids like needs something to do that's physical.
They're the little bodies have the little little batteries overflown with
energy.
I'm just saying do that.
They're shit was all about like grabbing,
throwing,
breaking,
breaking.
Yeah.
Do you remember being a kid?
Yeah,
I already did that.
Yeah.
So this is normal,
this whole thing of like,
like,
well women aren't aggressive like that because you know a solid standards.
Yeah.
I think it's,
they're aggressive in life.
I think that they,
they Lilly from like just survival shit.
They are looking in like,
all right,
that's what I have to compete with.
And there are,
you see them looking at the boys who appear to be dominating and what they are
is they're actually showing all of their carts and the little girls are already
taken an in breaking them down knowing,
well,
I can't get physical with this person.
I can't like dominate this person physically.
This is definitely,
and they just immediately stuck on like that's why they're fucking smarter than
we are.
I think.
No.
Did I lose you somewhere?
And then I don't necessarily think they're smarter.
I think
going on is that uh,
men have different DNA and the genes are aggressive and men are supposed to be
doing reckless shit.
Right.
Well,
I'm just saying it's nice to,
society didn't sit down,
they didn't watch three cereal commercials and they'd be like,
oh,
I need to be fucking this.
I just think that's,
that's just some,
uh,
bullshit that adults come,
came up with and uh,
does adults,
it's almost always women.
It's women that think that there's something wrong with the way men are raising
their sons.
They think there's something like this idea of these men raising these kids and
these kids being aggressive is because the way they've been coached.
That's not true.
It's just,
that's just a part of being a boy.
This is a shit ton of studies.
If people wanted to actually look at the science,
I mean if you leave boys alone with toys and girls along with toys,
boys would gravitate towards trucks and fucking,
you know,
the things that they can hit and smash and girl sit down there with a little tea
cops and they play with dolls.
It's natural.
It's just a hundred percent natural.
Yeah.
It was a documentary on babies.
You know what they,
bees are gender neutral.
The raising their kids gender neutral,
so they don't call them a boy or a girl.
And
my thing with that is there's no way.
You're not saying to your son,
you're sure you don't want to wear the dress.
And then the kid wants to fucking Ed wants to parents' approval.
Yeah,
I didn't want that football.
I guess I wanted the dress and it's just like,
like I said,
you know,
my kid's barely too,
so what the fuck do?
Why?
No,
I'm just saying my limited experience at kids' birthday parties is,
it's not even how it was ever even questioned that like they're too fucking too
young.
The fucking year and a half,
two years old,
like the telling me that society has already occurred.
Yeah.
They had.